they talk it's scary to not wear this
hat my old friends but this hat it gives
me it gives me power away
I love Hillary I love everyone right but
the campaign I'm with her just didn't
make me know that the guy they didn't
get to see my dad all the time like a
guy that could played catch with his son
there was something about when I put
this hat off and made me feel like
Superman
you made a Superman I wasn't that's my
favorite superhero and you made a
Superman cape that was quite something
Louis question love this guy right here
let me get
I love this guy right here that was
quite something the words of President
Trump in the Oval Office today Kanye
West expressing his support among other
things and that's where we'll start with
our panel
Josh cross cross cross our political
editor for the National Journal Amy
Walter national editor for the cook
Political Report at BA Hemingway senior
editor at The Federalist couldn't get it
out there Josh
that was something today too in the
words of President Trump what does that
do I mean it's it was a surreal moment
on TV we hadn't seen anything like that
in the Oval Office what do you think it
does for president Trump or the election
in any way it certainly was a surreal
moment and President Trump loves
celebrity yeah Mike love of the Beach
Boys he had a few other celebrities in
the White House today but you know it
reminded me that this could be a lost
opportunity for for president Trump if
he focused on criminal justice reform
which is why Kanye West was at the White
House in the first place that could have
been an opportunity opportunity early on
in his presidency to expand his
coalition to win over some African
Americans to the Trump side I mean it
really was sort of an amazing moment
where you had one of the most famous
african-american celebrities really just
hugging a president Trump but it feels
like it's a little late in the game for
that and it doesn't feel like this came
at the right time for this president
there's certainly some opportunity as we
get closer to the midterms for Trump to
build some new supporters but I don't
think he's gonna really move the needle
a whole lot politically Molly it was
interesting when he just said there
something about putting on the hat gives
him power and I think there is something
in our culture where there's a lot of
criticism of being a conservative a ton
of criticism for being a Trump supporter
but if you can withstand that criticism
there is something empowering about it
and I think that what's interesting
yeah Kanye's interesting he's always
interesting he says things in a weird
way certainly but I think the reason why
you're seeing so much negative reaction
is because of some of the things that
Josh is raising you have a very
prominent black celebrity aligning
himself with the president and there is
something very threatening about that
not just in terms of celebrity but also
in race issues and you're seeing a lot
of polls where you have like tons of
Hispanics supporting Ted Cruz tons of
Hispanics supporting Dean Heller Donald
Trump himself got more black votes than
Mitt Romney there's something that
people feel very nervous
about when people do not play the parts
they're supposed to to that point some
other commentators weighing in on what
was going to happen today with Kanye
West Kanye West is what happens when
Negroes don't read now all of a sudden
Kanye because he's put on a Magda hat
and he's an attention [ __ ] like the
president he's all of a sudden now the
the model spokesperson he's the token
negro of the of the Trump administration
liberal would try to control a black
person through the concept of racism
because they know that we are very proud
of emotional people so when I said I
like Trump to like someone that's
liberal they'll say oh but these races
you think race is okay control me I mean
it's such an explosive thing to talk
about but Amy how does this play I just
think we are back where we've always
been in the discussion of to America is
in a polarized America and that's really
where a lot of this discussion I agree
with Josh it didn't really spend a whole
bunch of time talking about the issues
that we thought we're gonna get raised
Kim Kardashian his wife of course came
in and actually talked about issues
related to criminal justice reform
instead this becomes about which team
are you on are you gonna be on the red
magnet hat team or are you gonna be on
the other team and the entire Trump
presidency has been basically about
picking your side picking your team and
for Kanye to put the red hat on then he
literally is saying I'm going against my
team and there's a backlash to that in
the same way that Republicans who have
said or people who were normally red
going to the blue team they get the
criticism for doing that there is
nothing left there is no middle there's
not going to be a middle and this
election is just going to I think
further get us into these deep deep deep
polar polarized world we've been talking
about tribalism for a while but it's a
little bit earlier this morning Donald
Trump called into Fox & Friends and he
had a lengthy conversation about
criminal justice reform and he was
referencing Kanye's appearance and it
was because of Kanye coming to visit Kim
came to the came to the Oval Office and
it's kind of like your
and what are these celebrities doing
there she actually was very effective at
commuting and getting that sentence
commuted but these are conversations
that people are having now and it's good
to see them on the right because
criminal justice reform has been
something that previously people just on
the Left seem to talk about a lot you're
seeing a lot of really good developments
in terms of questions about mandatory
minimums and and how we how we
adjudicate various cases and this is
happening because it's because of these
well the biggest impediment to this
actually is sitting in his cabinet and
that's Jeff Sessions Republicans want to
pass this they have the votes in the
Senate to pass this who may not be for
long after all is the real reason why a
lot of this stuff isn't getting done I
want to turn to a big international
story and that is this missing saudi
journalist and how the saudis are
dealing with and how the u.s. is dealing
with it we're looking at very strongly
we'll be having a report out soon we're
working with Turkey were working with
Saudi Arabia what happened is a terrible
thing assuming that happened I mean
maybe we'll be pleasantly surprised but
somehow I tend to doubt it I've talked
to Sarah corker Cardin in a bunch of the
people's Menendez there'll be a
bipartisan tsunami building against
Saudi Arabia here if they did in fact do
this it's very unlikely that he left
alive and it's time for the United
States to actually lay down some
consequences for the Saudis this is the
disappearance of Jamal Khashoggi and the
Washington Post is citing intelligence
sources saying that there were
intercepts showing that Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman himself was the
order ordered this action Josh what
about this and do you think the u.s. is
going to change dramatically its
relationship with what has been an
improving relationship with the kingdom
that's not what the White House seems to
want and and I've been struck by the
president's passivity and not really
calling out Saudi Arabia he says he
wants to wait till more facts become
available and this is like a lot of
foreign policy issues you see the
president leading from behind the
Republicans in Congress you see Lindsey
Graham you saw Marco Rubio also some of
the Hawks on the Senate side that really
want action they want sanctions that
they want to have some arms steals
retreated but the White House doesn't
want to do that and then Jared Kushner
has been a had a close relationship with
the Saudi leadership and
I think they have a lot they want to
contain Iran they have a lot at stake
with the Saudi a relationship and they
don't want to jeopardize it yeah I think
would hurt the message today from
Heather now ardh was let's see where
this takes us what we know to be facts
obviously there's intelligence that
we're not seeing that's what I'm going
to say is how are we going to know
actually are we going to feel like it's
a very definitive case that we can that
can be solved we may get more
intelligence and if so then the action
would really be to do the thing that as
Josh pointed out the president does seem
very hesitant to do which is to stop
sales especially arms sales to Saudi
Arabia and you could have a really
tremendous impact on the Saudi their
infrastructure and what they are doing
right now their place in the world
militarily if the US did put sanctions
on the arms sales I think people are
very much jumping the gun here both
Turkey and Saudi Arabia are allies they
also both have many human rights
problems turkeys air Dewan has
imprisoned something north of 160
journalists the idea that you would just
take them at their word that they know
exactly what's going on it seems really
premature and when you're making
decisions about how to deal with allies
you should always be focused on your
national interest kidnapping or killing
a journalist is a horrible thing this
happens a lot that a lot of people get
kidnapped and killed it's not worse if
it happens to a journalist than someone
else but you still have to make your
decisions about what's in the best
interest of your country and not get too
emotional a state I will say that I
think Congress is unified on this pretty
much across the board but we will see